[Music]
Buddha was born the son of a wealthy
King some 2,500 years ago in the
Himalayan mountains of Nepal after 29
years of living in luxury he left the
palace for the first time outside he saw
ordinary people and immense suffering he
decided to live a simple life spending
most of his time amongst holy man or
meditating his goal was to solve the
mystery of suffering over the years but
it came to the realization that we
suffer because we desire things to be
more than what they are
he spoke of Four Noble Truths one there
is suffering two suffering is caused by
our desires three we can manage our
desires by changing our perspective
instead of trying to change our
circumstances four we can free ourselves
from suffering by following the Noble
Eightfold Path also known as the middle
way the middle way teaches us to consume
in moderation cultivate self-discipline
and strengthen our mind through
meditation and mindfulness so we become
aware of our thoughts and actions and
realize that nothing is permanent we can
then understand that everyone is exposed
to suffering and as a result become more
compassionate with enough practice we
can let go of all negative desires and
free ourselves from suffering altogether
we reach full liberation of the mind
Buddhist schools in Thailand India and
around the world bring introspection
into the lessons and activities of their
national curriculum since Buddha
believed that wisdom is rather a habit
and not an intellectual state of mind
learning by doing is key but students
also practice concentration and learn
life skills like farming and skilful
communication to build intrinsic
motivation children get individual
feedback instead of reward and
punishment students learn to understand
and manage their emotions an angry girl
identifies the causes warning signs and
transient nature of her fee
earnings she might realize that we are
not being punished for our anger but by
our anger a boy that a stern maths test
reflects on his success he understands
that hard work pays off but also
realizes that he should not be too proud
because it separates us from others and
creates loneliness he learns to be
modest daily rituals help the students
practice mindfulness in the morning
students meditate in front of a shrine
chant Buddhist virtues and send out
feelings of goodwill to all living
beings sometimes students visit the
community to experience the pleasure of
giving and to see that some are
suffering they understand that nothing
is permanent not even life itself the
goal of a Buddhist education is to spark
a curiosity for lifelong learning
through reflection so that once we grow
up we understand the consequences of
skillful speech we learn to enjoy the
simple things in life and we find
inspiration and wisdom in our own
thoughts just as Buddha said conquer
anger with non anger come to badness
with goodness conquer meanness with
generosity conquer dishonesty with truth
[Music]
thanks for watching even if we try to
keep it short each video is quite some
work first we research and write a
script then we brainstorm ideas and
after that we draw the storyboard then
it is recorded narrated and finally
edited if you want to support us to make
more videos on learning and education
visit patreon.com slash sprouts
you
[Music]
you